I wanted to mention this quickly just to
sort of backstage business to tell you
about earlier today a true story at
rehearsal we do rehearse we we we looked
at a sketch and we cut it from the show
because it just wasn't funny and we
wanted to make room for other stuff that
wasn't funny so and yeah we do
occasionally cut things we do have some
standards that's true and we looked at
this thing it just was like now that
doesn't work so we cut it here's the
thing the sketch that got cut had a live
goat in it and we cut it and I found out
just after we cut it that we've already
paid for the goat yeah now what do you
think it costs to rent a goat just for a
couple of hours for a sketch I'll tell
you how much it costs seven hundred and
fifty dollars
yes seven hundred and fifty effing
dollars that includes the trainer that
includes transportation seven hundred
and fifty bucks a manicure and then I
asked well what are the guests get when
they come on the show what's Dana Carvey
one of the funniest people alive getting
to be on this show because you get yeah
it paid you get a payin a mum guess what
Dana Carvey is getting I don't know four
hundred and fifty dollars so let's get
this straight
Dana Carvey a immediate icon for for
anyone anywhere in my generation a
comedic icon is getting $40 a goat right
who doesn't even have to show up on the
program is getting 750
I bet - I bet you that the goat shits on
the floor more than Dana Carvey lies
right now they're both tied at three
apiece oh yeah Wow
yeah anyway I'm not letting this goat
get off the hook right without having to
do something let's go so you guys want
to see you go
[Applause]
Wow
it's now this he doesn't have to go the
hole he doesn't have to go the whole way
across the room that's gonna take 40
minutes
let him go no way he's walking so slow
he's ashamed of how much money he got
Hey
now let's see it
let's see if Dana Carvey can have as
exciting an entrance on you Dana
[Laughter]
you